foreign
[Music]
also has to understand that this
clotting occurs also without the drug if
all the vaccinations would cause
clotting we would have seen it right
away so the question is is there
anything with some of the vaccines or
with this specific batch that is
currently under investigation what I
know right now it does not look that
this is the cause and what we also need
to understand is that kovitz the disease
covets obviously also induces clotting
of the body and this risk is much higher
than what we can estimate if from the
understanding that I have I do not think
that there is a massive effect of the
vaccine on the clotting system
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
side effects so if you have received the
flu shot for example you have the pain
in the in in the arm you may have
so-called flu-like symptoms
so I think um it's it's it's showing
that the body is reacting to to the
vaccine
[Music]
well if you would have a lot of vaccines
available obviously that would be very
easy to say like okay just just wait put
that on a hold we just use another one
and then you know that's the Johnson
Johnson is is coming out uh maybe
Sputnik will be approved and so we will
have more vaccines available in the
future right now we don't and
unfortunately it is a race against
um the demotation of the virus which is
a normal biological process but if we
are able to really vaccinate people as
quickly as possible ideally on the
global level then we can win that race
that we are faster than the virus
[Music]
foreign
concerns about data in the 65 years and
older people were saying that we just
don't have enough data whether the
vaccine is is actually effective so we
lost several weeks there before we got
the data from Scotland in the UK and
that that clearly showed that this
vaccine is very effective and there was
a certain
reservation from the public to say like
I don't want that truck and so that's
why pretty much that drug was not as
much used as as it could have been so
yes we're losing a time and obviously it
is a new new stories or reports of the
side effects will not help it will
really put a break on the programs and
we have to
probably use more weeks to get everyone
vaccinated that would like to be
vaccinated
foreign
[Music]
decision and every country and other
countries are looking at this too are
evaluating their data whether there's
any reporting of increased clotting or
any side effects and if there's any
doubts then vaccine will not be given up
to people anymore for a specific time
period until that has been clarified we
we should not forget that millions of
people have received a vaccine and
um only very very few really have been
reporting serious side effects
and down on the investigation whether
they actually causedly linkable to the
drug or not
it shows that the scientific system is
working that
[Music]